it's back to normal Greg all eyes on
Capitol Hill today where President
Trump's new Supreme Court nominee judge
Brett Kavanaugh is meeting with
lawmakers many Democrats already
fiercely opposing the new High Court
pick but Trump is reminding everyone
what matters mostly making his selection
for the Supreme Court in keeping with
President Reagan's legacy I do not ask
about a nominees personal opinions what
matters is not a judge's political views
but whether they can set aside those
views to do what the law and the
Constitution require the White House say
it expects Kavanaugh to be confirmed by
October firs ahead of the impending
political battle the Supreme Court
nominee is sharing insight on ruling
from the bench if confirmed by the
Senate I will keep an open mind in every
case and I will always strive to
preserve the Constitution of the United
States and the American rule of law and
as we mentioned liberals are losing
their minds over president Trump's pick
former Democrat Virginia Governor Terry
McAuliffe tweeting Cavanaugh's
nomination will quote threaten the lives
of millions of Americans while Nancy
Pelosi is vowing to quote avenge
President Obama by fighting Trump's
nominee and more Democrats promising
obstruction watch the ramifications of
this battle will last a generation and
more I'm going to fight this nomination
with everything I've got
if you are a young woman in America or
you care about a young woman in America
pay attention to this because it will
forever change your life
we are in the fight of our lives so this
seems to be them of all the people the
most self-serving person he could choose
in order to protect himself from this
criminal investigation and to avoid a
constitutional constitutional crisis we
cannot let this confirmation process go
forward okay so as predicted dana of
course there's gonna be opinions it
wouldn't be like liberals versus
conservatives if you didn't have a
little the ping-pong back and forth so
as predicted they went a little bit not
so they would have been nuts about
anybody who was selected however someone
here at this table has personal
knowledge and experience of judge
Kavanagh raise your hand do you put you
in jail once yes welcome spent a weekend
in Tahiti well I guess it'll come out in
the papers it will first on the idea
that that Brett Kavanaugh is so
objectionable what's interesting about
the opposition is that last night they
had all of their signs made up and then
they would take a sharpie and write in
the name as soon as it was announced by
President Trump at 9:00 p.m. so they
really sort of handmade sign so no
matter who was going to be nominated
they were going to face this I think
that Terry McAuliffe's tweet probably
would have said no matter who it was
that this means that millions of people
are going to die and so the opposition
is definitely spun up I'm curious about
how that will play out and I think we'll
deal with that in the future in terms of
like what Gillibrand and Kamala Harris
were just saying right then how that
will play in terms of not just the
midterms but I think 2020 and 2024 and
beyond I do think a lot of it is scare
tactics but that's what a lot of people
use truck Schumer is facing a very
interesting situation he has a base that
wants him to fight and he says I'm gonna
fight with all that I have but even with
all that he has because they do not have
the power it will not be enough so at
some point he's going to have to let
those red state Democrats go and decide
on their own if they want to vote with
the president and if they want to win
reelection they probably will want to do
that a personal note about judge
Kavanagh so I knew Brett Kavanaugh
before he was a judge I
at the in the white house with him one
thing I didn't know until they said last
night and I know his wife as well I
didn't know that their first date was on
September 10th 2001 ooh and it was the
next morning when they were walking into
the White House that the Secret Service
started pulling people out because of
the impending danger they're a wonderful
couple I loved his interaction with his
daughters but I will say that what his
job was at the staff secretary's office
was to build consensus one of the worst
things you have to do imagine Greg if
you had to submit your monologue to 20
offices and everyone got to take a whack
at it and I was the staff secretary and
I got to negotiate with everyone I'm
changing this word or that word that was
really his job there it wasn't a legal
job per se so the idea that they want to
see every email he ever put through in
the White House as a staff secretary
does be seems like it's not relevant to
how he would rule on the law all right
fantastic I'm so glad I went to you for
thank you I'm sorry I'm so much done an
excellent decision
okay so Greg what do you have to offer
in it isn't reminiscence about Tahiti I
was just thinking about the first date
with September 10th I mean I would be
worried about the second date I mean
what what could happen I would just be
bad beautiful this process now is no
different than the ball possession and
football so when you have the ball ie
the White House you put points on the
board that means you pick as many judges
as you can and if you're on the defense
naturally your job is to block the
points you don't want that you don't
want the judges in there so right now
the Republicans have the ball then
Democrats don't have the ball so what
they're gonna do is no matter who they
put up there is going to be not just
unqualified but evil Wow this is going
to be an evil person and my favorite
part is how everybody is like an instant
expert on this guy when they never heard
of him before it's like people who
became fans of the Washington Capitals
when they were in the Stanley Cup it's
like suddenly they knew everything about
hockey but this used to be separate this
whole system used to be separate from
politics until one word Bork if you
remember the hearings of Robert Bork
here was a brilliant mind that was
poisoned by political venom everything
changed with pork you could like he was
crucified and he mean people were
befuddled by the attacks on him and ever
since then I don't think that the
Democrats were always like
I don't think the Republicans have
always been pushovers on this but I
think that's got to change
I think we have to look at this now
sadly as a political turf war and and
fight as hard as possible as they do
because they're going to Bork everybody
Bork was the first time when the media
they broke that political seal they took
a brilliant mind and they destroyed him
well be back a hundred percent welcome
back you've been how many boards are on
your boy thank you very much
hanging out would kill me because a
little bit of sports corner there sports
analogies with basketball I like why do
have a exit with one fact Cavanaugh was
born in 1965 Ted Bundy graduated from
high school in 1965
I'm not saying Cavanaugh is a serial
killer but I'm not not saying he's a
serial killer we have no evidence but do
we need evidence if he's evil thank you
for presenting both sides thank you
thanks Farren unbalanced well I'm
unstable as well all right what do you
have to say about this what do you think
we were predicting yesterday we thought
perhaps Cavanaugh Barrett you predict
together yeah I like ferrets in fact I
was on here I thought Hardiman was the
guy but I think that actually you know
some people in the White House put
pressure on the president cuz I think
Cavanaugh is much more connected than
Hardeman ever is gonna be except of
course Mary Ann Trump Barry I think is
her last name
served with Hardiman on the third
circuit so I bet she was pumping him to
her brother but I think that the last
say really came down to Don Magan who's
the president's White House Counsel and
I think he and others really are tapped
into cabin on he is the Republican
establishment pick which is why he's a
Kennedy Clerk just like Gore's that's
right and I think the problem for
Senator McConnell was there's such an
extensive paper trail so it's not just
that we don't know much about him as
Greg said but that there is so much to
be found out because I think somebody
said he's a little bit like Forrest Gump
wherever you look a big issue oh there
he was there he was in the star
investigation into President Clinton
there he was in the Bush White House in
the midst of so many controversy
and there he is on the DC Circuit and on
the DC Circuit for many years so when he
was nominated for the DC Circuit I think
it's oh three there was a three-year
delay in terms of confirmation because
people wanted to know more about him
some people said he was a political guy
who became a judge I don't know I don't
want to be unfair to him I mean you got
liberals like Akhil amar at Yale who are
making the case for him it's thoroughly
qualified and deserving of the
appointment the difference is and I
think this is something I want to say
both to Dana and to Greg in the way that
they postured is that oh it's anybody
that the left was going to oppose you
remember that if that this election the
list came from the Federalist Society
and heritage so it's not a universal
easy to say oh give me some qualified
conservative judges to consider no these
are people who the far right has put a
stamp on in terms of abortion Kavanagh
is not qualified you're saying I didn't
say that what are you because he was
part of the list your son no no I
commissions I didn't say that at all
what I'm saying is these are people who
have been pre-screened Jesse for their
conservative credentials by far-right
conservatives he worked for Justice
Kennedy he was applauded by george w
bush as an excellent choice oh I don't
understand what the problem is you even
have legal scholars and on the liberal
side and and Democrat side saying that
this is someone who's eminently
qualified and was a good choice I don't
find him to be far right or fringe
whatsoever and I don't see any evidence
of - well that statement I don't think
there's much doubt that he's qualified
served on a TV circuit for ten years but
that's not the point in a politically
polarized country where at the moment as
everybody here says by the way you would
basically what you're going to have is
five hard-right boats that will control
America for generation to come and of
course the people who say wait a second
I don't want the court to just be rubber
stamp I want a fair hearing a five my
case is before the court I want to know
that I'll get a fair hearing yes I would
say election I would say that Democratic
presidents also nominate liberal
justices to the Supreme Court it's not
just Republicans that nominate their
side it happens on both sides and that's
fine and that's how the game is played
it's interesting to say the biggest
criticism against cab
he worked for Ken Starr I thought
special counsels were beyond reproach
and beyond partisanship but I mean
independent prosecutor listen they've
been calling this guy a reactionary
ideologue he's going to end civilization
as we know it he lives in the Maryland
suburbs with his wife Ashley and his he
coaches his daughter's basketball league
maybe it's a front he serves hot meals
in his Catholic charity the guy is not a
monster he's like a polished gentleman
who went to Harvard have you tried those
hot meals impeccable credentials and
pretty much everybody thinks he's going
to be a very very strong judge he's got
a very long history of decisions and
scholarship and I think that's a good
thing because then you can really see
how he is a solid pick and he's got a
great sense of humor and has Greg knows
anybody with a good sense of humor is
brilliant he's hilarious
he is hilarious and you saw that last
night the end people saying roe v wade
he's actually on record as saying roe v
wade is settled law and he's going to
file it on that issue and then
politically if you think about it
I think Schumer can't do anything about
it unless some surprise comes up in his
paperwork which we don't know if that's
going to happen yet but you were saying
the other day Manchin hide Camp Joe
Donnelly all Senate Democrats up for
reelection they all voted for Gorsuch so
I don't see why they're not going to
vote for Kavanagh as well they're
spending a lot of money on this pick
with national ad campaign advertisements
and bottom line Schumer comes up small
in these big moments he botched the
shutdown I think he's gonna botch this
battle with it well I think Manchin has
said that there's pre-existing
conditions is something that really
concerns and he says 44% of his state
West Virginia would be impacted he wants
to know how he deals with that I think
you're going to see a lot of people say
let's get the paperwork let's take the
time no need to rush it and you're going
to see Mitch McConnell say no let's get
this done before the 59% of West
Virginians want this confirmation to
happen
I just want to say one one you mentioned
that this Court will rule over America
for a generation and I think that
actually is a fundamental issue here
with the court the court is actually not
meant to rule over anybody the people of
America are supposed to rule over
themselves and the court has been used
by the left as a place to establish long
desired policy goals that they couldn't
get done through the people through the
Legislature's through the Congress and
the and the Supreme Court is all that
it's supposed to do is to say
constitutional not constitutional that's
it so the idea that the court has this
much power is not correct why add more
people to the court no one could that
would what if I was Trump I would add I
would say let's make it 16 a 17 because
then you want the majority detailed
opposition research the Democrats have
had this you know for over a year since
he had to replace then fill Scalia's
position so everybody's research them
and vetted him and checked him out so
they can stall but they can't put it off
they can run but they'll die tired I